the Joe Rogan experience another problem
that I had in the film especially in
relations to sport is the Nate Diaz
Conor McGregor comparison yeah first of
all Nate Diaz is not a vegan Nate Diaz
eats fish and he eats eggs yeah and he
he does try to follow a whole food vegan
diet I think during camp so I would have
to talk to him about that I know he's
done interviews talking about that but
I've definitely seen him eat fish I
watched him on the Anthony Bourdain's
television show and he was eating fish I
know he's eating eggs he doesn't eat
land animals I think what he does is
avoids red meat fish and eggs take care
of it yeah you know fish is actually
higher often and than meat in terms of
protein ounce ounce per ounce it's also
very high in collagen which is super
important for recovery and repair and
explains lack of collagen probably
explains why a lot of vegan athletes get
injured which we can talk about more
later and then eggs as you know are
super you know they're really high on
the Dia's score scale they're
bioavailable lots of other nutrients so
here's another problem with that whole
comparison first of all Nate Diaz is a
fantastic fighter he's a long time
mixed martial arts veteran he's
outstanding in all areas he has a
fantastic submission game his brother
Nick Diaz one of the best in the world
he's also outstanding and all and his
brother Nick I believe is vegan he's
probably a better example cuz you know I
mean even though Nick hasn't beaten like
some of the top-flight fighters in a few
years back when he was in Strikeforce he
was top of the food chain he's he's an
elite fighter for sure I'm not sure if
he was vegan back then I'd have to ask
him but the point being that nate is a
exceptional exceptionally skilled
athlete and he was coming into that
fight on extremely short notice so he
was most likely following his off camp
diet which is eggs and eaten fish and
things along those lines partying in
Mexico so who knows what the [ __ ] he was
doing it was like 11 days out they call
him and they set up this fight I forget
how many days out it was but it was a
very very short amount of time Conor was
preparing for a 155-pound fight against
HOF Aldo San Jose so he was reducing his
caloric intake
dropping his weight down to try to make
this hundred fifty five pound weight
class it's a big cut for him so when
when you do that you you are in
anticipation that the person you're
fighting is also doing that so you both
kind of agree that you're going to be in
a certain weakened state when you
actually weigh in at 155 pounds like two
weight classes below his normal let me
go make it keep going
so he's this is that was the first and
only time that well except that rematch
with Nate was the only time that he's
fought at 170 so they made a decision to
fight at 170 instead of 155 because Nate
did not have time to reduce his calories
and cut the weight and it takes a long
time it's a slow process of neza big
fella he walks around probably over 200
pounds easy and he drops weight and he
didn't want to drop that much way he's a
big guy man he's big and long and Conor
was dropping his weight down to 155 so
he's 10 days out and he just starts
packing on food eating as much food as
he can
not only that but stylistically Nate's a
nightmare for him Nate has a [ __ ]
evil submission game he's tough as nails
his endurance is always fantastic
because offseason he's always doing
triathlons and he's always doing like
endurance sports I mean he's in
phenomenal shape and his jujitsu is like
many levels better than Connors I mean
he's a legit top of the food chain mmm a
black belt in jujitsu so they have this
fight
Connor gets tired Nate beats him up gets
him on the ground submits them and
they're saying this is a victory for
veganism what they don't say is five
months later they fought and Connor beat
him they fought again they fought they
this time they had a full training camp
Connor prepared and it was a very close
fight I should say you could have vote
you could have scored it either way I
mean it was a really close fight razors
thin but the fact remains
Connor beat him in the rematch so I'm
going to leave this out of the narrative
like oh my god the vegans are dominating
look vegan dominated but he's you know
this is a last minute fight Connor goes
up and wait Nate Diaz
you know steps in and and takes care of
business and wins the fight it speaks
more to how good Nate Diaz is than a
vegan diet right and it doesn't take
into account that four months later or
five months later whatever it was he
loses and he's not vegan
you know I mean there's their few
fossils it sometimes there are a few
other examples like that in the film
where you catch like a certain window of
it but they don't show what happens
afterwards we talked about the vegan
honeymoon so Brian Jennings the boxer
yes they talked about he went vegan in
end of 30 2013 he was 17 and no before
he was vegan and he's been so he's seven
and four after that so you can't say
that that's because he transitioned to a
vegan diet but you can also say NORC nor
can you say that veganism improved his
performance right I mean it it
objectively he's gotten worse since then
well the the argument against that would
be that he's moving up into the upper
echelons of the heavyweight division and
it's filled with killers like any combat
sport and that as he got in many
fighters don't make it to get in and he
lost to wasn't one of the Klitschkos yes
I think he lost to Vladimir I think he
lost a Vladimir Klitschko and a decision
and he handled himself very well it was
a very good fight for him he looked real
good but yeah I mean that that upper
alone you get to these andy ruiz Deontay
Wilder I mean killers yeah it's like not
most people that get up into that
division they start losing HP here's a
good example too of this principle of
context being everything because he said
in the film my early years growing up in
Philly the only thing we knew was
spinach and a can collard greens and
Popeyes KFC everybody frying chicken I
grew up not even knowing about half
these other vegetables asparagus to me
just came out like five years ago right
so you know again early honeymoon yeah
going from going from like a crappy
standard American diet to a Whole Foods
diet I don't doubt that someone's gonna
feel better but what do you felt better
like you said eating some grass fed
bison and some a Bellini along with all
of those plans yeah that's the question
[Applause]